boom freeze michael schoon fbi you know
what you did
this is real it is a screenplay
starring himself
agent michael scarn inside the fbi agent
michael scarn sits with his feet up on
his desk catherine zeta jones enters
sir you have some messages not now
they're important
okay
what are they
first message is
i love you
that's for me not in a thousand years
catherine we work together and get off
my desk yes i have acted before i was in
a production of oklahoma in the seventh
grade
i played the part of muti the mailman
they had too many kids so they made up
roles like that
that was good
if it isn't my old partner samuel l
chang
agent michael scarn
you lost some weight
thank you for noticing
now keep me company for one more mission
hey i have to work but as soon as i blow
out these candles i'm registered
michael scaron takes out a nine
millimeter gun and shoots the cake
hahaha agent michael scarn you so funny
word
michael's movie
two thumbs down
a man sitting several seats down who has
a gold face turns to michael scarn uh
ooh
oscar you want to play golden face
mr scarn perhaps you would be more
comfortable in my private jet yes
perhaps i would golden face sam get my
luggage i forget it brother
samuel you are such an idiot you are the
worst assistant ever and you're
disgusting twigged wait who's dwigged
here's what we think happened
michael's sidekick who all through the
movie is this complete idiot who's
causing the downfall of the united
states
was originally named dwight but then
michael changed it to samuel l chang
using a search and replace but that
doesn't work on misspelled words leaving
behind one
dwight
and dwight figured it out
oops
d-w-i-g-h-t
okay you know what i am done with this
that said the end well
some of us want to keep reading uh you
don't speak for everyone jim okay
announcement
my uncle bought me some fireworks and
anyone who wants to see a real show come
with me outside now
that's actually a good idea we'll all
take a brief intermission we have a lot
of angry customers out there this puts
us at threat level midnight accounting
you are on customer service duty today
that's really not our job midnight oscar
we have a lot of angry customers out
there this puts us at threat level
midnight accounting you are on customer
service duty today that's really not our
job midnight oscar
we have a lot of angry customers out
there this puts us at threat level
midnight accounting you are on customer
service duty today that's really not our
job midnight oscar
i got a delivery for you leave it at
reception
i'm supposed to live with this one in
person
me
[Music]
[Music]
clean up on aisle five
[Music]
after three years of writing one year of
shooting four years of reshooting and
two years of editing i have finally
completed my movie
threat level midnight
die
[Music]
one two one
nice try golden face except you forgot
one thing to kill me oh i wasn't trying
to kill you
i was trying to slow you down
no
oh by the way
yeah
how's your wife doing
[Laughter]
bye
bear me billy
you don't look so good what's got you
down i got problems billy big problems
you got problems my tv don't work i pay
30 bucks a month for the damn satellite
what's a who's it i can't even get the
damn game hey you tell me what's worse
than that
don't ever change billy
golden face is going to blow up the nhl
all-star game tomorrow
i see what you mean about problems i
know it'll cheer you up
that table of bachelorettes over there
bought you this drink
hey
ever banged an entire bachelorette party
baby
why are you singling my line out like a
million years later
i'm too depressed to save the big game
billy i'm gonna cheer you up the only
ways i know house
hey kid
hit g9 on the jukebox no billy i haven't
done that dance since my wife died
there's a whole crowd of people out
there who need to learn how to do the
scar
[Music]
well my name's michael son and i'm here
to say i'm about to do the song in a
major way
[Music]
you jump to the right and you shake a
hand and you jump to the left and you
shake that hand you meet new friends you
tie some yarn and that's how you do the
scone you jump to the right and you
shake the hand and you jump to the left
and you shake that hand meet new friends
tie that yarn that's how you do the
scarring
you jump to the right and you shake that
hand
meet new friends tie that yarn that's
how you do the scarf
if doing the scarring is gay
then i'm the biggest queer on earth
i'm sorry i'm really
really sorry i think i was just relieved
to see that michael strong got his
confidence back yeah michael the movie's
amazing it's like one of the best movies
i've ever seen in my life you should
enter it in festivals or carnivals
thoughts
pretty good reaction pretty cool
right
did you like it did you like that
which part
no it's not good enough it's not good
enough some people are really popping on
screen hey hey
good movie um
good everybody out there says it's great
i loved it did you what did you love
about it um
i love that you got to work together
with all your friends
isn't that so great when you can all
work together like that no no holly this
isn't ocean's 11 where you get together
with all your friends and you just have
fun and you don't care about how it
turns out
what'd you really think honestly
um
is
is it because you're afraid of where
this is gonna take me because i need you
to keep me grounded
not worried about that
it's 11 years okay
this has been my dream for 11 years
and if you don't think it's great then
you're basically saying you don't
believe in my dream
it's your dream you never even mentioned
it before we talk about a lot of things
holly
you know i was eventually going to get
around to my dream
obviously
11 years that i could have been working
on the scar nebulous why do you have to
make a movie at all because if i don't
have this what do i have i have nothing
really you can't think of anything else
that you might have i have my book on
business somehow i manage i have my hbo
comedy special here i go again dot dot
dot but you know what when i think about
it when i really think about it none of
those things
are as real to me as my movie
i'm real
yeah you're real pain in the ass
and now i'm gonna go watch the movie
with people who think it's great
and i'm sorry i called you a pain in the
ass
i'm angry and i love you
i love you too
[Applause]
[Music]
hey
we got sports games again
[Applause]
some breakfast for me
some breakfast for you
[Applause]
oh yeah i guess i did let him be a robot
oh
yeah
threat level midnight makes all the
girlies feel all right from madonna to
madeleine albright threat level midnight
it's a threat a level a level level
threat he's the greatest hockey star
i've ever seen yet friend level what
midnight threat level who michael scorn
threat level y apartheid gotta find it
free mandela peace i'm out
you